German prosecutors say that the killing
of a georgian man in berlin last year
was ordered by the russian state the
german government saying that it is
taking the prosecutors statement very
seriously saying that it may take
further steps against Moscow over the
matter including imposing sanctions now
the victim was a Georgian citizen of
Chechen ethnicity who fought against
Russian troops in Chechnya he was killed
in broad daylight into the German
capital last August following the
prosecutors statement the Russian
ambassador to Germany has been summoned
to the foreign ministry in Berlin and
for more on this I'm joined now by Roman
Goncharenko from DW Russia service tell
us because the German government is
considering what we've heard our quote
further steps against Moscow over the
matter what could that look like well
that's a 1 million dollar question first
it's a complicated case and it took the
German prosecutors almost a year to
investigate it so now we have the
indictment and now the German government
has announced we could consider further
steps first you have to think about how
did Germany handle such cases in in the
past and we almost have no experience
with that the only comparable case is
the poisoning of this [ __ ] a circus
crippled in the United Kingdom a few
years ago by Russia and then we had a
joint European response and at that time
Germany expelled for Russian diplomats
in this case Germany has expelled two
Russian diplomats so far but not in
connection with the case itself but for
for Russia not cooperating enough on the
investigation that was what the German
government said in December so now I
think we could see more Russian
diplomats being sent home we could
probably see some Russian officials
maybe from The Secret Service FSB put on
a certain list and they will not be
allowed to travel to Germany but I think
Germany might try to get a European
response to that so I was at several
countries in a joint action expel
Russian diplomats something like that
but I
don't think that a German will go as far
as imposing economic sanctions on Russia
because it's a very very sensitive issue
okay so that's nonetheless and
potentially major consequences here for
for German and perhaps also EU Russia
relations the murder happened now back
in August 2019 we mentioned that that
now these German prosecutors have come
to these conclusions why did it take so
long well there are several reasons
reasons I think the number one is it's a
very very sensitive case and the
prosecutors tried to use every
possibility and draw no hasty
conclusions because they know very well
that this might have political
consequences thought it just took the
time they needed and then there are
several other reasons for example the
suspect was not traveling under his own
name so the German prosecutors first had
to establish his real name and Russia
was not cooperative on that just like I
said and this took some time to
establish the facts and one other reason
is of course that the suspect is not
telling is not cooperative with the
police with the investigator so he's not
giving any details
he's just being silent and this of
course makes it more difficult to
investigate Roman Goncharenko from DWS
Russia service thank you so much for
putting this dramatic announcement into
context for us